has to um put it to the likes of the
Israeli Defense Force in Gaza U are you
really uh being as careful with civilian
lives as you possibly can that's a fair
question to put the answer has to come
in terms of the circumstances there's no
as it were general rule here the
question is what is what is it you're
trying to achieve militarily what means
are you using uh could you use means
that would uh Expos fili to to fewer
risks is this military objective really
important uh but depending on the
answers the answer could be uh we can't
minimize civilians any any further uh
and we have to pursue this military
objective um even at the cost of
considerable civilian casualties